The dream of every Muslim is simply to
be treated the same as any other New
Yorker. And yet for too long we have
been told to ask for less than that.
This is the correct religion. This is
the religion that all of humanity needs
to be a part of Islam and we will not
stop until it enters every home. The
dream of every Muslim is simply to be
treated the same as any other New
Yorker. America will be a Muslim
country.
Russia will be a Muslim country. Islam
will enter every house. We have to be a
part of that change. The dream of every
Muslim is simply to be treated the same
as any other New Yorker. The prophet
says, "The first thing you do is call
them to Islam.
If they accept it, leave them. Call us
their Muslims. We go. If they refuse,
then tell them Allah obliged upon you to
pay taxation. If they refuse, then
>> [clears throat]
>> we have to fight.
And if we fight you, then we capture
you, you become our slaves, and we take
your land, and you take where because
you refuse. I give you two good options.
The dream of every Muslim is simply to
be treated the same as any other New
Yorker. But for the European white
people complaining about immigration and
Islam, first of all, I want to tell you
that Islam is going to take over every
single
square inch
of
the globe.
The dream of every Muslim is simply to
be treated the same as any other New
Yorker.
>> [music]
>> The dream of every Muslim is simply to
be treated the same as any other New
Yorker.
The dream of every Muslim is simply to
be treated the same as any other New
Yorker. Okay, you know the other
argument is uh but okay, so if you don't
like it here, go to your own country.
How can you tell us to go? We're not
going nowhere. We are here to stay. Like
I said, we're not here to take part.
We're here TO TAKE OVER.
>> [laughter]
>> THE DREAM OF EVERY MUSLIM IS SIMPLY to
be treated the same as any other New
Yorker.
The dream of every Muslim is simply to
be treated the same as any other New
Yorker. But when you when you when you
ask when you say that you're saying your
speech in French, you said things like
we will conquer the world, we will have
the flag at the White House. You got to
understand people get
you know, they get scared of that. They
get pushed back from that. I mean,
you're you're saying we're going to take
over your country.
And maybe you're not saying that, but
maybe Quran says Yeah, no, I'm saying
that. Why of course. And Michael said it
and I'm repeating it. Of course.
And we will take over. Of course we will
take over. Just if you look at the
numbers, of course we will take over.
The dream of every Muslim is simply to
be treated the same as any other New
Yorker.
The dream of every Muslim is simply to
be treated the same as any other New
Yorker. Of course there are Hadith and
predictions of the prophet that before
the end of the world, Muslims,
inshallah, will rule the world. The
dream of every Muslim is simply to be
treated the same as any other New
Yorker.
promised us victory over these major
powers. One of the promises of the
prophet
is that the day of judgment will not
happen
until Islam prevails
and we become victorious and we will
rule the whole world. The dream of every
Muslim is simply to be treated the same
as any other New Yorker. And yet for too
long we have been told to ask for less
than that.